boy oh boy does Game Pass have a lot to
choose from so much so that it can be a
little daunting to know where to even
begin but don't worry in this video
we're going to go over what's new and
some of the gems worth checking out on
Microsoft's gaming service
vampire survivors emerge from obscurity
to being one of the most talked about
games of the year and while it's been on
PC game pass and Early Access it has
finally Unleashed its official version
1.0 on Xbox consoles it's a single stick
shooter where all you need to do is
control the movement of your character
while it shoots and fires weapons and
abilities for you but don't be fooled by
its Simplicity the longer you stay alive
the more overwhelming herds of enemies
become forming hundreds as they surround
you on all sides it then becomes a dance
of maneuvering through an ever-growing
horde while strategically stacking
power-ups to fend them off now this is a
rogue light so the levels are always the
same but the power-ups you receive and
the order in which you do is completely
random the more you play the more
characters you unlock with each one
starting off with a specific weapon like
Antonio who has a whip or gonero with
throwing knives or Poe who starts with
garlic which is the single most
satisfying damn power up this game has
because it basically allows you to just
walk through crowds of low tier enemies
without a single care in the world as
approachability lends to countless hours
gone as it'll have you entrance by its
vampiric Gates and The Addictive nature
of just trying one more time to either
stay alive a little longer or unlock a
new character is the first sign that you
know it has sunk its teeth into you
thankfully it's a small download size
and an absolute no-brainer if you're
looking to just shut your brain off
after a long day
history art and murder meet at a single
point in the 16th century Adventure game
pentiment this is through and through
and inspired and bold exploration of
European life in the 1500s underpinned
by art social class politics philosophy
and religion all neatly wrapped up in a
murder mystery that spans decades you
play as Andreas a master artist who
finds himself entangled in the middle of
a murder and all the scandals that
unravel with it in trying to find your
friend who is tied to the murder
innocent you'll spend most of your time
talking and getting to know the many
towns folks hear their stories and get a
magnified look at common folk of the era
in so many ways well the mystery is
Central pentiment is an intimate look
into history but through the lens of the
people living it rather than how we're
used to seeing it often academically and
through a textbook which is you know
boring for some of us on your journey
you'll get to decide who Andres is using
light RPG elements shaping his
background personality all of which
determines your responses in certain
scenarios and the ability to navigate
more turbulent encounters most of the
choices you make will have a ripple
effect that spans Years and may even
influence the development of the small
village in which the game resides
Norco it's a surreal Southern Gothic set
in a dystopian sci-fi depiction of New
Orleans Suburbia in this text-based
point-and-click adventure you return
home after being gone for five years and
learning about your mother's death only
to learn that your brother is missing
your journey to find him will take you
through the Sullen streets of a sunken
surreal suburb left dilapidated by a
corporation that tore it all apart for
its oil refineries
for how serious and Melancholy the game
sounds it is actually remarkably funny
genuine and at times bursting with
warmth and heartfelt prose it manages to
deliver a moving story about family
corporate tyranny even religion and
Technology while never feeling overt
instead it delivers it cleverly through
the characters you meet and they're
often quirky stories and I assure you
this game goes to some rather
Fantastical places speaking personally
this was very high on my game of the
year list and I just about recommend it
to anyone even if text Heavy visual
novels aren't your thing I'd still
suggest popping on to click about the
Moody and Atmospheric pixelated World
also make sure to listen to the guy's
story about eating a hot dog and I mean
like the whole story
what else can I say to introduce a game
that starts every single level with a
giant Banner that says kick their ass
this is a game where you play as a dude
with the worst posture in gaming history
wielding a casket gun and dual pistols
shooting everything in sight with each
enemy erupting like a water balloon
filled with guts and blood this is the
most video game ass video game I have
played all year and you know what I
don't even know if it's good all I know
is that I shot non-stop for an hour
straight and I still have no idea what's
happening this game and like this dude's
deformed posture I couldn't care less
because I am a badass dude with a big
collar and glasses permanently resting
on the tip of my nose despite twirling
in a ballet of gunfire and violence this
is a game that in its own description on
Game Pass uses verbiage like Graves the
Gunslinger of resurrection and badass
anti-hero of your dreams or become the
ultimate killing machine brutalizing
your foes without mercy and you know
what I'm like [ __ ] yeah dude this is a
game about having unlimited ammo
listening to loud music and swinging
around a giant casket that beat the crap
out of dudes and monsters and stuff and
it's cool so in the case that a 16th
century mystery isn't for you or you'd
rather not read your way through a story
like Norco then what else could possibly
tickle your gaming fancy other than a
game where you play as a dude head to
toe in leather blowing everything in
sight to shreds
or you know we could just dial things
back slightly with Somerville
[Music]
Somerville is the Sci-Fi puzzle
Adventure debut of Studio Gem Ship which
is made up of some of the folks that
brought us Classics like limbo and
inside following a similar style to
those games Somerville will have you
traversing a civilization in the midst
of a cosmic hostile attack forcing you
to make amends with your family in the
face of an utter catastrophe through
ravaged forests and Fallen cities you
have to find the whereabouts of your
family while dealing with an alien
invasion the game features a stark yet
vibrant art style despite its rather
dire narrative
and like limbo and inside you'll be
solving environmental puzzles and often
running for your life and hiding to
maneuver dangerous encounters
additionally observing aliens at times
will be vital in your survival and how
to understand their technology
based on real events the legend of Tian
ding is a beat-em-up set in 20th century
type pay where you play as Leon Tian
ding a sort of Robin Hood style
vigilante that robs the rich feeds the
poor and serves Fists Full of Justice
this is a stylized hard-hitting action
game that is just bursting at the seams
with grit and fists most impressively is
how well it manages to incorporate its
Chinese manga art style into the game
itself using Illustrated panels as a way
to emphasize moments and even attacks in
a way that feels really reminiscent of
something like Beautiful Joe and I am a
hundred percent here for it
Ghost Song is an absolute Cosmic Terror
with a striking art style that is as
dark as it is dazzling you are a dead
suit long dormant now awaken on a
desolate Moon that is stricken with
Mysteries twisting Caverns secrets and
Galactic monstrosities in proper
metroidvania fashion you'll explore the
world discovering secret places its
haunting history and of course new
abilities that allow you to backtrack
and slowly unlock the world but not
without scary spooky stuff to stand in
your way thankfully you're not entirely
alone you'll encounter a cast of
characters along the way where you'll
get to piece together more of the
mystery and the terror that surrounds
the Moon
[Music]
okay that's it hope there was something
on this list that interested you this
month for Game Pass has been one great
game after another so I implore you to
at least check out something on this
list that you may not have considered
otherwise in the meantime I'm going to
kick their ass
thanks for watching